good morning John I'm extremely excited
to announce that today with the hard
work of nerdfighteria and I might add
with some amazing detective work by you
we have tracked down Gussie Audrey
horsey Gowen manlove Brown we also
learned a lot of things about the past
and go to the fact that there used to be
a lot of women named Gus oh the guys
he's gone so starting with a marriage
record the two people found on that
tombstone we were able to devise that
Gussie used to be Gussie Audrey horsey
Gussie horsie of course being the worst
possible name for a young lady but
interestingly in her marriage license to
Walter man lab she was listed as a
divorcee well it turns out that her
family took on boarders and one of those
borders was a 28-year old man named
Charles gaol Gussie at that time was 16
years old
so cool there's some amazing detective
work we have discovered that Gussie and
Charles R gallon had a baby daughter
named Mary she was born in 1901 when
Gussie was 17 or 18 just after they got
married they divorced soon after the
birth of Mary and Charles kept custody
of the girl
this marks hurt first to name changes
during the marriage to Gussie Audrey
gallant and then after the marriage to
Gussie Gowen horsey Gussie perhaps
because of her divorce figured that she
was never gonna get married and so she
took up a trade she became a typesetter
something that she did for a long time
in her life but then in 1911 ten years
later when she was 28 years old she did
find a man she found Walter manly now
Gussie is Gussie Gowen man love and then
tragedy struck four years after their
marriage Walter died of tuberculosis
resulting in the tombstone that started
this whole circus he had by now changed
her name again to Gussie Audrey man law
then for ten years after the death of
Walter man loves she lived in boarding
houses with other single women working
as a typesetter and at one point suing a
mattress salesman will Gussie be Oh
during this period she changed her name
again this time her first name going by
Audrey G man love instead of Gussie a
man low it's like she's messing with us
say conmigo
say I'm a horsie men evoke a twin always
the same that's not my day
but then in 1927 Gussie married again to
a man named James Earl brown this marks
the final name change of Gussie - Audrey
G Brown using all this information that
we figured out John Green was able to
find the obituary and the final resting
place of Audrey G Brown our Gussie they
bought a house together in a nice
neighborhood in Indianapolis they lived
in that house the rest of their lives
their house is now for sale and you can
go on the internet and look at the
pictures of the inside of that house and
it is very strange and if you want you
can buy that house and you can be a part
of this very strange long epic story of
Gussie Audrey horsey Gowen manlove Brown
Gussie Audrey horsey cow
we found Raven was you
we tracked you down
I hope that you don't mind
poking Ram thank you to John and all of
the nerdfighters in your pants worked
hard tirelessly hours and hours of time
to track down all the fascinating
information about this woman's life
proving once again that everything is
more complicated than it first appears
but if you live in Miami Seattle or
Portland something isn't complicated you
should come see me play a show that is
right I have scheduled a Miami show and
it's coming up very soon on the evening
of March 8 Tuesday the reason I'm going
to be in Miami is somewhat complicated I
don't have time to discuss it right now
really but basically I am going to be
going with water.org to Haiti and I have
a night an evening in Miami in which I'm
not doing anything so I decided heck I
should rent a planetarium and play a
show seriously I'm playing a show at the
Miami Science Museum in their
planetarium
I am so geeking out about this but since
it cost some money to rent a planetarium
it does cost money to get into the
planetarium to see the show and there's
a link for those of you who are in South
Florida to buy tickets to come and see
me in Miami exciting stuff going on
throughout nerdfighteria John I will see
you on Monday